hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the first essay of the genealogy of
morals particularly
in chapters one two and three
we see these discussions of
english psychologists references to
people who they're on the right track in
a certain way
but they also go about things in the
wrong
manner and don't provide us with a
genuine
genealogy of morals that nietzsche
himself is going to
take himself to provide in this this
work
and there's a number of puzzles that
arise when it comes to this the first
question we can ask is well
who does he mean who is he referring to
who are these english
psychologists we we have two names
that are being mentioned in the course
of this and it would be very tempting
for the casual reader to say
aha paul ray herbert spencer
those are english psychologists
and there's some problems with taking
that
point of view um herbert spencer
okay he is an english psychologist right
he's also a philosopher
and a writer on a whole bunch of
different subjects he's one of these
people who very few people
read today but who was a very important
part of the philosophical scene
in not just england but also america and
europe
in the 19th century particularly the
late 19th century
but when he's being mentioned he's being
mentioned
as not falling into the same mistake
as the english psychologist as we'll
talk about with with
nietzsche's second main criticism the
implausibility of this
forgetting so spencer might exemplify
this to some degree
but he's also if he is within the
english psychologist he's on the outside
of the circle
what about this guy paul ray who gets
mentioned
in the beginning in in the preface of
the work
ray was actually a friend of nietzsche
but ray is not english
and so that seems to raise the problem
he you know he's actually from prussia
so
can he be one of the english
psychologists well nietzsche tells us
this
the first impulse to the first impulse
to publish something of my hypothesis
concerning the origin of morality
was given me by a clear tidy and shrewd
also precocious little book in which i
encountered
distinctly for the first time
an upside down and perverse species of
genealogical hypothesis
that attracted me with that power of
attraction with everything contrary
everything antipodal possesses the title
of the little book
was the origin of the moral sensations
it's author dr paul ray the year in
which it appeared
1877. i've never perhaps i've never read
anything to which i would have said to
myself
no proposition by proposition conclusion
by conclusion to the extent that i did
with this book
now i left out a little phrase in that
and we'll add it here so for the first
time a perverse species of genealogical
hypothesis
the genuinely english type
so although rey himself is not
ethnically
english nietzsche seems to be saying
that rey who he knew quite well and
actually traveled with
was in fact of the english
type so maybe he can be placed in here
who would the others be well you know
some people have suggested
he's reaching way back and you know
hobbes and hume
that's pretty implausible it seems more
like although
there are cases to be made they are
adopting kind of a genealogical approach
to at least certain things when it comes
to morality but
it's it's really impossible to say and
anybody who tries to tell you they know
exactly
who nietzsche means is either deluded or
lying to you
so we can instead focus
on what is nietzsche's criticism he
thinks that they
are getting something right sort of uh
they're taking a genealogical or
critical approach
and what do we mean by that so they are
looking at moral concepts and sentiments
and vocabulary and sort of
tracing it back to its its origins
now tracing its back tracing these
things back to their origins
means telling a kind of story of
development
and they have a story of development but
their story
has to do with utility and
the group dynamics and things like that
and nietzsche thinks that that's
actually
wrong he also speculates a bit about
what we can call their motives and this
is very typical of
nietzsche he's not just interested in
what people are saying and not just
interested
in why they're saying it in the sense of
what are the justifications he's also
interested in
what are their actual motives what are
they trying to
achieve by saying things in this way
so he let's look at uh chapter one he
says that they are no easy riddle
i confess that as living riddles they
even possess one essential advantage
over their books
they're interesting these people are
interesting even though their books are
boring
these english psychologists what do they
really want
we always discover them at the same task
dragging the
party ontos the shameful bits of our
inner world into the foreground and
seeking the truly effective and
directing agent
that which has been decisive in its
evolution in just that place where the
intellectual pride of man would least
desire to find it
in the this inertia of habit for example
or forgetfulness
or in a blind and chance mechanistic
cooking together of ideas
or in something purely passive automatic
reflexive molecular and thoroughly
stupid
what is it that always drives these
psychologists in
just this direction why are they
engaging in this demythologizing or
demystifying uh
you know bringing things to light about
stuff and saying ah it's just this
that's going on
we might ask similar things about
similar genealogists in the present oh
it's just neurology
right it's just brain states
evolutionary biology
put us in this way nietzsche would say
those people are basically like the
english psychologists
so he asks is it a secret malicious
vulgar perhaps self-deceiving instinct
for belittling man or a pessimistic
suspicion
mistrust of disappointed idealists or a
petty
subterranean hostility and rancor
towards christianity and plato
or a lascivious taste for the grotesque
the painfully paradoxical
the questionable and absurd in existence
or finally something of each of them a
little vulgarity
a little gloominess a little
anti-christianity a little itching a
need for spice is it is it any of these
negative things is that why people are
engaging in that and you could say for
some of them yeah maybe
this guy or this person over here just
like we can in the present
anita says i rebel at the idea
that they are just creeping around like
frogs
i don't believe it and if one may be
allowed to hope where one does not know
i hope from my heart they may be the
reverse of that that these investigators
and microscopists of the soul may be
fundamentally brave proud and
magnanimous animals
who know how to keep their hearts as
well as sufferings and bound
and have trained themselves to sacrifice
all desirability to truth
every truth and so he's trying to put on
you know the best face
possible for these people
maybe some of them actually do fit that
we don't again we don't know because we
don't know who these
uh english psychologists are nietzsche
does think that they've got some things
fundamentally wrong and by seeing this
we get to glimpse what his own project
is going to be in the genealogy
so the big criticism right off the bat
is they claim to be doing something
that's historical
but they're really a historical and this
is actually you know
quite a good criticism of this
by the way a similar criticism gets made
by jean-jacques rousseau of
thomas hobbes and other you know people
talking about the state of nature and
social contract
that what they're doing is they are
interjecting the human beings of the
present
into a story about how human beings
develop from the past
and they're taking wrongly the
array of sentiments and habits and you
know dynamics that we have in the
present
as being determinative of primitive
human beings
so he he tells us
it's certain that the historical spirit
is lacking in them
that all the good spirits of history
have left them in the lurch
as is the hallowed nature with with
philosophers
the thinking of all of them is by its
nature
on historical they've bungled their
moral genealogy
because the task is to always
investigate the origin
of the concept and judgment good so
where did this notion of good come from
is it something
just basic and primitive or can we
attribute it
to something and notice what he's saying
here it's it's the
uh judgment that we're interested in
not just the word itself so
what's the problem nietzsche says that
they
are creating a narrative that
essentially
circles around and makes central
concepts that are coming from an english
kind of psychology and what are these
key concepts utility forgetting habit
and error and this is where we might be
tempted to say okay maybe hume is part
of this picture
or maybe it's jeremy bentham or maybe
it's
jon stewart mill or maybe it's uh maybe
it is indeed
hobbes because some of these things do
come to light even though
hobbes and hume aren't utilitarians hume
certainly uses the word utility an awful
lot to explain things
so what is their point of view nietzsche
says originally
one approved unegoistic actions and
called them good from the point of view
of those to whom they are done so those
to whom those actions are useful so
you know we're cavemen and i
you know start a fire and i welcome you
to the fire and you're like oh that's
that's nice i don't have to start my own
fire which is a real
bit of work for me and i'm going to call
that action good because it benefits me
it has usefulness for me
right and then if you do something like
that for me i'm like oh that's good and
eventually
we use the word good for these
unegoistic
actions and he says
one later one forgot how these approval
originated and simply because unegoistic
actions were always habitually praised
as good
one also felt them to be good so there's
an affect developed right as if there's
something good in themselves
and he says this is typical english
psychologizing right
we have the typical traits of the
idiosyncrasy of these people
as the basis of an evaluation of which
the higher person has been
proud as though it were kind of a
prerogative of the human being
as as such and
you know nietzsche says look this is
implausible um
it didn't happen this way where's your
historical evidence
you know you're just sort of like
telling a cool story that that's a you
know
a maybe thing that you elevate into well
it must have turned out this way
anita also says another thing that's
really interesting here too he says
you're looking for the value judgment in
the wrong
as he says place but really we can say
in the wrong persons
and so he he tells us it's plain to me
that in this theory the source of the
concept good has been sought and
established in the wrong place the
judgment good
did not originate with those to whom
goodness was
shown rather it was the good themselves
who felt and established themselves and
their actions as
good that is of the first rank and so
we're going to go
into that when we talk about the primary
valuation
so nietzsche is saying your history
is not a history to begin with and it's
actually wrong
and if we go back into history and we
look at how these terms were used by
people
it's actually the people who are labeled
as good who are calling themselves good
not the ones who are benefiting other
people there's something else going on
here so that's important and he also
says that the
the english psychologists are
essentially reflective of their own
times
and of the dominant form of morality
which nietzsche is going
to call a number of different things but
herd morality
is is one of them he says it was only
when aristocratic value judgments
declined that this whole antithesis
egoistic
unegoistic obtruded itself more and more
on the human conscience
it is to speak in my own language the
herd instinct that through this
antithesis at last gets its
word and its words in and so that is
what these people
these english psychologists are taking
as their starting point
not realizing that that itself is the
product of historical developments
and sort of a set of blinders to put on
so they're getting things wrong
criticism number two is is quite
interesting he says this forgetting
that's supposed to have happened is very
implausible
you're telling a story that that if we
strictly look at it
we shouldn't believe in so he asks how
is this forgetting of the useful
or to other people actions possible and
he says
why would we forget that it's more
likely that we would highlight it and
here's where he credits
spencer for getting something right he's
like listen herbert spencer
says that you know this is what's
driving things within the group and
within morality
but he leaves out this aspect of
forgetting
that is as nietzsche says impossible
um the opposite he says must have been
the case
if our focus is on usefulness of
one's actions to other people and we
think that the value judgment
good comes in uh in that way which is
what herd morality is then the more
useful things are the more we're going
to pay attention to it the more it's
going to get reinforced
so these are some some pretty you know
solid criticisms from nietzsche's
perspective
and he's saying that the english
psychologists
you know they can get the ball rolling
but now we need a different sort of
approach to a genuine genealogy of
morals
you